-Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's team
is speaking out
about their final report.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The one thing --
maybe the only thing --
Donald Trump loves
about being president
is campaigning for president.
Whenever he's in the White House
doing his actual job,
he looks like he's waiting
in a doctor's office
for a colonoscopy.
But then, when he's on stage,
in front of his adoring fans,
he lights up.
I mean,
just look at the difference.
It's like the before-and-after
from a Prozac commercial.
That is the face of a man who
just heard the phrase,
"Good news, there are
no criminal charges."
In fact,
Trump was clearly ecstatic
after his attorney general,
William Barr, sent a letter
claiming that Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's report
had not established a conspiracy
between Trump's campaign
and Russia.
And Trump has spent
nearly two weeks celebrating,
despite the fact
that he doesn't actually know
what's in Mueller's report.
-It's a disgrace what happened.
This was a terrible thing
that was put onto our country.
Nobody's seen
anything like this.
Probably never happened before.
Beautiful conclusion.
I haven't seen the report.
-A beautiful conclu--
You just said
you hadn't seen the report.
I'd love to hear his summary
of "The Sixth Sense."
"I haven't seen the movie,
but it's beau--
everyone's alive at the end."
And even...
Even if you had seen the report,
it's nearly 400 pages.
There's no way you'd be able
to actually make it
to the conclusion.
I doubt you've ever read
anything that long in your life.
If you locked Trump in a room
and told him,
"Don't come out until
you've read the whole report,"
you'd open the door the next day
and see him surrounded
by Big Mac wrappers
and cans of Red Bull,
hair disheveled,
bags under his eyes,
and you'd say,
"How far have you gotten?"
and he'd go, "So far, Matt.
'Written by Robert Mueller.'
[ Laughter ]
And then I hit the wall."
Still, even though Trump
has not seen the report,
he cannot help
but ramble on and on
about how he'd been vindicated
and how he defeated his critics
at a rally in Michigan
last week.
-After three years of lies
and smears and slander,
the Russia hoax is finally dead.
The collusion delusion is over.
They tried to divide
our country,
to poison the national debate,
and to tear up the fabric
of our great democracy.
And they're on...artificial
respirators right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're getting
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation.
-They need
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation?
Every time you do a rally,
you look like a guy
in an episode of "Baywatch"
who fell off a party boat and
got dragged back to the beach
by David Hasselhoff.
When you give a speech,
you suck in air like
you're about to go underwater.
-[ Inhaling ]
-So, Trump's handpicked attorney
general looked over the report,
decided Trump had been
exonerated, Trump celebrated,
and we all took his word for it
and moved on, until last night,
when Mueller's team
started to speak out.
-Breaking news overnight.
The New York Times reveals
the Mueller report
may be far more damaging
for President Trump
than Attorney General Bill Barr
has led on.
The Times says some of
Robert Mueller's investigators
have told close associates
that Bill Barr did not
adequately capture the findings
of the nearly
two-year-long probe
in his four-page summary
to Congress.
-And the fact
that we're even hearing this
really means something
because the Mueller team
never leaks to the press.
I mean, look at him.
Robert Mueller's wife still
doesn't know his middle name.
"That's between me
and the government."
So, now they're saying
Barr's summary,
the one Trump spent two weeks
celebrating, is inaccurate.
Wow, when Trump heard that,
he needed...
-Mouth-to-mouth resuscitation.
-Look, we don't know
what's in the full report.
We have no idea
if there's anything shocking
or significantly different
from what's in the Barr summary,
but it's remarkable
that Mueller's team
is suddenly speaking out
to reporters
after two years of
total and complete silence.
It's like when you try to get
the Queen's Guard to flinch,
and they're just
totally still for an hour,
and then you go, "Let's
get in line for the tour,"
and they say,
"It's called a queue."
[ Laughter ]
Mueller's team
is apparently frustrated
in part because they actually
wrote up several summaries
of their findings themselves
for public consumption,
and Barr ignored
all those summaries
and chose to write his own
that said the president
had been exonerated.
-Mueller's team
had written some summaries
around this report,
and that those summaries,
they anticipated,
would be something
that Barr could use
to be made public,
and that it wasn't,
and so there's
frustration there.
-"The Special Counsel's
investigators
had already written multiple
summaries of the report,
and some team members believe
that Mr. Barr should have
included more of their material
in the four-page letter
he wrote on March 24th
laying out
their main conclusions."
-So Mueller's team wrote their
own summaries for the public,
and Barr chose to ignore those
summaries and write his own.
As a general rule,
I'm always suspicious
of anyone who chooses
to do more work
when they have
the option not to.
I mean, we don't actually write
a new "Closer Look" every night.
We just buy it from a website
called politicalrants.com.
Tonight's "Closer Look"
was written by...
Gary from Oregon.
Thank you, Gary.
[ Applause ]
Give it up for Gary, everyone.
The "It's called a queue" line
went better than I thought.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans have been eager
to declare Trump exonerated
and quickly move on
from all that
rather than wait
for the full report.
In fact,
Trump and his aides have said
they want to take their victory
and set the stage
for the 2020 election.
Last week, for example,
Trump's former strategist
Steve Bannon
took human form
and appeared on CNN
to tell Anderson Cooper
he didn't think any Democrat
could compete with Trump
in 2020.
-At the end of the day,
the Democrats, I think,
are gonna focus on somebody
who can beat Donald Trump,
and they're gonna search
for that.
It's not gonna be
a policy discussion.
It's gonna be electability.
And if you're gonna beat
Donald Trump as an incumbent,
you're gonna have to bring it,
right?
You're gonna really
have to bring it.
In the field I've seen so far,
I don't know anybody
that can hit a fast ball
like Donald Trump can throw.
-First of all, Steve,
thank you for joining us
from the other side.
[ Laughter ]
What's going on with you, man?
You look like the ghost
of a dead ghost.
I mean...
[ Applause ]
That whole thing
looked like an interview
with a before-and-after
of a guy who takes Prozac
and a guy who snorts it.
[ Laughter ]
Second, of all the things that
you can say about Donald Trump,
he cannot throw a fast ball.
Have you ever seen him
throw out the first pitch
at a baseball game?
Look at his face.
He looks like he's farting
and pulling a muscle
at the same time.
This is why we need to see
the full Mueller report
as soon as possible.
For two years, we've been
waiting for answers,
and instead, we've been getting
lies from the president
and unconfirmed rumors
going from...
-Mouth-to-mouth.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]